[Música]
o primeiro golo num dia
obrigado a organização do evento por
convidar a gente ouve um pouco mais
sobre ações de lá um pouco mais sobre
nossa história e bom é um pouco
desafiador em todos os sentidos porque
então esse projeto não fazia parte dos
planos falar tanto e tantas vezes em
público
muito mesmo muito menos para um público
como vocês então é uma honra
obrigado por terem vindo e isso aqui é
solo firmado né
as pessoas que estão passando aqui pela
coragem da história das pessoas que
fazem tudo que estão fazendo bom é a
minha expectativa é fazer um convite pra
vocês no final desses 18 minutos e ter a
certeza de que se não todos pelo menos
uma pessoa dessa platéia aceitar esse
convite e eu acredito que se nós
exponencia lizar mos isso com a proposta
que está por trás
nós podemos mudar a vida de muitas
pessoas e isso sai um pouco do mérito de
que parece que salvar vidas pertence só
determinados profissionais ou
determinadas circunstâncias
é isso que a gente está mostrando com
esse projeto mas nada que me apresentar
sou já que o exato
eu sou um hacker ativista e a minha
experiência é na área de segurança
corporativa
foi com isso que eu ganhei a minha vida
durante muitos anos
foi isso que eu fiz pra poder construir
as coisas que eu construí até hoje é o
que eu tenho conversado muito com as
pessoas é o seguinte conceito o que a
gente consegue fazer com três horas e
vinte eu pessoalmente em três horas e
vinte ou três horas e meia de curitiba
pra cá eu li um livro de parte de um
livro colocar em dia os meus projetos ou
eu posso me deslocar de curitiba pra
praia que a gente não tem o mesmo
privilégio que vocês têm aqui
poucos minutos está na praia mas existem
outras circunstâncias que quando a gente
olha três horas e vinte parece que é
impossível de se fazer alguma coisa por
exemplo vamos pegar na seguinte situação
todos nós se não somos
se não há médicos ou se a vocês já
tiveram contato mínimo com a área de
saúde
então entendi mais ou menos essa matriz
que eu vou comentar com vocês
imagine identificar o paciente tem um
problema chamar um especialista esse
especialista vai verificar os motivos
mas fazer outras solicitações
entre essas solicitações é pedir pros os
o time de apoio fazer os exames
solicitados exames coletar fazer tudo
que tem que fazer com relação àquele
paciente essa informação vai voltar pra
ele vai tomar uma decisão vai acionar
outro time quando a gente olha para esse
circuito até a solução final dela parece
que três horas e meia é impossível de
você conseguir realmente tratar toda
essa máquina corrigir todo o qualquer
problema que surgir nesse intervalo de
tempo
eu tenho escutado a maior parte das
pessoas que se o intervalo de tempo
impossível de se trabalhar
bom é pensando nesses três horas e vinte
que eu sempre comento pra todo mundo que
a minha motivação é a minha verdadeira
motivação é desafiar um cara um tanto
quanto grande um tanto quanto experiente
a minha motivação é desafiar cronos a
minha motivação é perguntar é questionar
se realmente o que ele nos dá é
inviolável
se aquilo que tem pra sair das coisas
que nós temos que enfrentar está
condicionado ao tempo está condicionada
às regras que regem o tempo se nesse
intervalo de tempo entre atingir este
objetivo um tanto quanto o tópico nós
conseguimos impactar a vida de um bilhão
de pessoas
nós estaremos no lucro então enquanto
isso não acontece a gente continua
tentando mas nesse intervalo de tempo eu
escolhi um
motivo eu escolhi um espaço para poder
trabalhar
e foi na área de saúde a maior parte das
pessoas não conhece ou não fazem idéia
do que seja a sepse
mas todo mundo já ouviu falar infecção
hospitalar ou infecção generalizada
bom a sepse ou a infecção hospitalar ela
a infecção hospitalar é motivo de 56 por
cento da mortalidade nos hospitais do
brasil
a cada 100 pessoas que morrem dentro dos
nossos hospitais
independente de quais sejam ele está não
estamos falando só dos hospitais
públicos ou só dos hospitais que têm
algum tipo de dificuldade estamos
falando de todos os hospitais do brasil
cada 100 pessoas que morrem dentro de um
hospital 56 delas são vítimas de
infecção hospitalar ou de infecção
generalizada ou tecnicamente de sexy
só que isso não é um cenário só do
brasil a cada dois minutos uma pessoa
morre por sepse no mundo ou seja isso é
um problema humano
isso é um problema nosso é um problema
da nossa da nossa existência
nós evoluímos muito sentido se nós
olharmos preciso números hoje e
compararmos com a peste ea frio afligiu
europa na idade média
se compararmos o que aconteceu com os
países da américa central na em 1500
a onde de 75 milhões até 200 milhões de
pessoas morreram por causa de bactéria
até então desconhecidas
talvez nós estejamos no lucro o problema
é que quando nós olhamos pra isso e
entendemos o quanto isso é influencia
toda a máquina de saúde e as outras
consequências que existem por conta
nós não conseguimos mensurar por onde
começar
quando eu comecei esse trabalho eu
comecei essa pesquisa e fiz alguns
dentes eu percebi que existe dois
grandes mercados que usam tecnologia à
indústria bélica e indústria
médico-hospitalar e uma delas
e uma é cliente da outra o que eu sempre
questionei foi porque que a indústria
médica hospitalar não é tão eficiente ou
tão assertiva quanto a indústria bélica
e às vezes usam os mesmos equipamentos
usam as mesmas tecnologias bom estudando
entendendo vem a maneira de nós
encaramos como que a gente resolve as
questões não existe outra maneira de
fazer algo do que fazendo como fazer
para resolver este problema
não sei se vocês já ouviram o conhece o
termo ceni acha sanear a china é o
mestre que ensina por exemplo é aquele
que vai faz ele não fica contando
história ou subindo no palco ele vai lá
e faz
então foi o que eu decidi fazer eu criei
o primeiro robô cognitivo do mundo que
faz gerenciamento de risco o robô laura
o robô laura ele tem 263 motores que
trabalham em tempo real
no intervalo de 3.8 segundos para
identificar quais são os pacientes que
estão em risco ou que estão na
circunstância de infecção hospitalar ou
que estão em sexy
não existe outra tecnologia parecida com
essa no mundo robôs cognitivos existem
anos a tecnologia cognitiva ou seja
máquinas que aprendem estão sendo
desenvolvidas
agora um que faça gerenciamento de risco
agora é o primeiro toque e como eu disse
pra todos vocês
é isso só vai funcionar se nós atingimos
quem precisa pois bem o que nós
desenvolvemos para poder resolver este
problema foi criar o sonho de laura e é
isso que eu vim apresentar para vocês
o sonho de laura tem um objetivo
específico e o que está por trás dele é
a parte da história que eu não conto
talvez poucas pessoas vão ouvir eu
falando essa parte da história
então se vocês me permite
vamos deixar que ela mesma conta essa
parte da história e depois disso a gente
entende como isso é possível fazer
porque tudo isso acontece
nani laura eu vivo no mundo das idéias
para passar do tempo eu fico imaginando
um mundo diferente do atual
atenção a diferença exigência do
algoritmo capaz salvaria o que eu chamo
de algoritmo da vida ele nada mais é que
um jeito criativo dias vê diversos
problemas como a fórmula brilhante que
serve para ajudar as pessoas
principalmente aquelas que correm risco
de morte nos hospitais é a chuva eles se
dão de ajudar os outros e meu pai e ele
é um cara muito legal
daqui a pouco falou mais sobre sua
vocação antes de escrever e contar um
pouco sobre minha história mas para isso
precisamos botar no ano de 2010
eu estava tão bem dentro daquela coisa
de água quente por mim estaria lá para
sempre mas algo tivesse saído do
planejado frança de bem estava com você
nasce antes do tempo com apenas 440
gramas e organismo frágil mas felizmente
tinha um monte de gente preocupada
comigo
os médicos enfermeiros não poupavam
esforços para muita gente que assim como
eu precisava de ajuda
mas eles fazem muito possível estavam
tudo de si para cuidar da gente também
pôde acompanhar de perto esse transe de
meus pais eles ficaram lá o tempo todo o
meu lado estava um pouco apreensivos mas
felizes também
o problema é que o organismo fragilizado
acabou sendo alvo de uma infecção eu
precisava de mais um cós títulos
seja lá o que for isso aprendi que eram
muito importante para a minha saúde
queria poder mandar toda essa situação
não é que meu pai e minha mãe não sofrem
tanto com tudo isso não pôde ajudar meu
pai
em razão de férias a partir da nossa
separação vai encontrar o tal um ritmo
do começo
aquele que salva vidas foram muitas
noites em claro tentativas e erros
uma coisa legal é que não desistiu e
ainda contagiou muita gente com essa
idéia
o que antes era apenas uma ideia hoje
virou um bordão
o mais legal é que muita gente também se
mobilizou para ajudar adivinhação ao foi
a inspiração para que meu pai
desenvolver seu grande projeto elzinha
esse projeto foi chamado de robô laura e
seu objetivo é gerenciar riscos e ajudar
profissionais da saúde com suas rotinas
o robô laura será um grande aliado no
combate sexy uma grande ameaça no
ambiente hospitalar e nada mais é que um
quadro de infecção generalizada
provocada pelo excesso de atenção coisa
mesmo da determinada infecção e deixando
outras partes do corpo na weiss colocou
lá é igual àqueles filmes de ficção
científica onde a inteligência
artificial como livros humanos e sim um
robô tempo e interagem para evitar erros
não consegue identificar a 7 antes que
seja tarde demais
por isso ele pode salvar muitas vidas
incrível não
eu que detesto quando os profissionais
precisam de ajuda
sei que o robô será muito útil seria
muito legal
todos os hospitais pudessem contar com a
ajudinha
assim quem sai
o fim da minha história poderia ser
reconhecido de muitas outras
obrigada time não deixaria por fazer de
tudo para manter isso na minha vida
[Música]
[Aplausos]
a motivação nunca seria a morte do ó até
porque pra mim com todo respeito que
vocês acreditam na hora não morreu só
mudou a interface
porque a pior sensação que eu carrego
nesta existência não digo que seja pior
sensação que um ser humano pode passar
porque não experimentei todas pelo menos
nessa existência ainda não é você sentiu
o calor de alguém subindo nos seus
lábios e foi só isso que ficou
registrado de nós dois
a partir disso do dia 29 de maio de 2010
eu dediquei absolutamente tudo o que eu
tinha tudo casa carro dinheiro tempo e
energia conhecimento amizades
relacionamento para poder disponibilizar
para a saúde no brasil tecnologia de
ponta acessível e eficiente
nós não quer nós não queremos enriquecer
com a saúde no brasil
a gente quer enriquecer a saúde no
brasil e existe tecnologia para isso nós
fizemos isso em casa
isso não está vindo de fora e se nós
fizermos isso nós vamos conseguir
reduzir em pelo menos cinco por cento a
mortalidade por sepse no brasil e como
consequência direta nós conseguimos
atingir em sua plenitude as metas das
odds 3.1 3.2 e três pontos de nós
estamos fazendo isso com um grupo de
pessoas com um nível de de profissionais
até hoje não conhecidos na história do
brasil
nós estamos conseguindo fazer uma
transformação massiva na saúde fazendo
com que a obra fique completamente
transversal à saúde usando o cluster de
curitiba como motivo
nós estamos saindo de 200 leitos do 1º
ano pra praticamente sete mil leitos até
setembro desse ano
isso só é possível fazer com
inteligência artificial não de outra
forma
a laura usa tecnologia de ponta tudo
aquilo que existe no mundo nada
diferente ela acesso de dados sistema
minérios informações paz
cientes ela isola os riscos e ela aciona
ansiedade laura ansiedade do órgão o
painel de gestão à vista que ajuda todos
os profissionais em tempo real todos os
profissionais do hospital
nós estamos cansados especialista todos
a identificar quem é o paciente que está
em risco
o hospital nossa senhora das graças que
foi o primeiro hospital teve coragem de
receber laura ele não só tem os painéis
como ele também recebe sms e emails
roubo isso totalmente autônomo não
existe ninguém do outro lado a equipe da
laura são oito programadores e três
robôs trabalhando construindo a primeira
tecnologia desse nível do brasil que
está sendo reconhecido em vários outros
lugares e que até o final desse ano vai
ter dar um resultado que até hoje
nenhuma outra tecnologia fez as
informações que todo mundo recebe em
tempo real são processadas pelo robô de
uma forma que até então o hospital não
conhece e além disso todos os gráficos
todos os resultados são compartilhados
entre todas as pessoas todos os
profissionais justamente para que todo
mundo possa ter essa informação em tempo
real
a expectativa no final desse ano é nós
aplicarmos a cidade de curitiba o
primeiro caso de monitoramento de
gerenciamento de risco para situações
epidêmicas até hoje não conhecidas
porque o robô está mirando a base de
dados de toda a prefeitura de todos os
laboratórios em 3.8 segundos a cada três
pontos segundo ele repete o próximo
então vocês lembram quando nós
conversamos quando comecei a palestra e
disse que o grande desafio era desafiar
cronos bom três horas e meia foi o tempo
que os médicos de equipe levaram para
identificar que laura estava em sepse
então desde o dia 29 de maio de 2010 no
meu desafio foi mudar isso e hoje o
hospital nossa senhora das graças passou
de 3 horas e 20 a 42 minutos o tempo
entre a visita do leite
[Aplausos]
nós reduzimos o tempo da máquina toda em
85%
então impactar um bilhão de vidas vai
ser fácil é só vocês aceitarem o convite
obrigado
[Aplausos]